she's gotta be under lives change
organizations guy [ __ ] yeah
organization
it might change the world
there needs to be a popular media
network in the US that represents the
views and values of moderate
conservatives fiscally conservative but
socially liberal and tolerant and
there's three reasons for this need
first without this voice slightly right
of center there will be a gap along the
spectrum of views and political
representation and incomplete democracy
second this gap this gap is polarizing
and that's not a good thing
and third given the stage of journalism
today where media businesses with your
ratings and profits
sometimes good journalism is
subordinated it's put second place and
this makes the polar polarization worse
now this is important to me because news
media has influenced me when I was
growing up in the US since I was 13
actually my parents were usually out of
town for months at a time and it was my
neighbors that took care of me and they
were a wonderful couple there was this
lady called Flo fiery she was the
cleaner at a local cinemas she was also
a passionate union leader of those
cleaners then there was her husband Ray
he was your typical salt-of-the-earth
Australian form from the rural Outback
traditional conservative and even though
it's been nearly 20 years I remember one
of his lessons very fondly he told me
Dino if you're in a fight and the other
man goes down that's it the fights over
there's no pudding in the boot to a man
on the ground i I really cherished my my
time with Flo and Ray we used to sit
down for dinner and we would watch the
nightly news
usually with watch a few channels for
different
spectres and I really enjoyed this the
open debate that we had
I mean flow would have her views she was
a union leader ray would have his views
sometimes they were opposed and strongly
served but I really respected the
openness of debate I really cherished
that you know we were all willing to to
be tolerant and listen to the other side
and over the years of having dinner with
Flo and Ray over the nightly news that
was how a lot of my beliefs and values
were built up and coming back now here
did the u.s. when I watched the the
media channels available here I can't
help but think how my debate with Flo
and Ray would have been influenced if
that voice coming out of that TV box was
a strong hardline position
I can't help but wonder how my beliefs
and values now would have been
influenced now this matters to me
because when I came here to the US six
months ago I was very excited I was
coming to the premier democracy in the
world and let's face it whatever the
u.s. does be it in trade capital markets
or that big stick the military it
matters to the rest of the world and I
was excited to be here but when I came
here I don't know if it was just
watching too much West Wing but I saw
something very different I saw two camps
polarized at opposite ends of the
political spectrum and I couldn't help
but think what role did news media play
in this polarization I asked my
classmates you know what what media
sources do you go to for your news for
your political views and they mapped it
out to me
they said all right Dean if you want the
conservative view you go and watch Fox
you listen to Rush Limbaugh ok and they
tell me right as you head towards center
you'll come across Wall Street Journal
ok
newspaper and it's mainly financial they
don't really have a social platform then
you have to go quite some way quite some
way I say National Public Radio then
there's also the Public Broadcasting
Service I've been told they're quite
neutral mainly educational but sometimes
a little bit of liberal bias that
sneaked in there then you come across a
CNN and the other major news networks
ABC and CBS and kind of out here what's
the little end of the spectrum now I
mentioned it there's a gap and this is
the gap that I'm talking about because
what's here right now there's a diaspora
of blogs of internet sites I mean yes
they're sources but there's no one
unifying voice and this lack of a of a
strong voice in this space here is in
this gap that almost is reflected in a
lack of political representation here
and this gap this gap becomes polarizing
I have reached out to a lot of campus
conservatives to try and better
understand that the political space in
the US and there were two stories that
really stuck out for me one was a
Republican and he described to me his
pain in the last election he said döner
my choices were the mccain-palin ticket
or Obama and despite being a Republican
he couldn't bring himself to vote for
the candidates that his party had put up
he felt that mccain-palin just simply
didn't represent the values that he
believed in he called himself a liberal
Republican and he ended up voting for
Obama
there was another campus conservative he
was actually part of the original Tea
Party movement he told he was very
excited as he described it he said we
were out there in the town hall meetings
reading the Constitution it was almost
like a pure intellectual movement
small-government about getting back to
basics about the individual rights but
what happened
he had Fox News Network pick up the
coverage picking up this movement then
he had Sarah Palin come in the movement
became popular and it shifted out to the
right and this campus conservative told
me I could no longer associate myself
with this movement it felt that this
movement has shifted out to a hardcore
fiscal conservative position into a
socially conservative position and he
felt that it was homeless became anti
intellectual and this is what's
happening here people here in this space
people here are being pushed out you
either have to go right or you have to
go left because there's no
representation here and that's not a
good thing
to add to this polarization this is
combination of sensationalism of poor
journalism and almost a repetition that
comes with the 24-hour news format this
combination has the potential to make
the polarization worse in fact I say it
makes the polarization worse let's think
about sensationalism what do we have
here when I started watching some of the
more popular Fox shows I was surprised
at the examples of liberals that they
were bringing into their shows I almost
heard that they were almost the worst
examples of liberals to represent the
other side I remember this one person on
the Hannity show a Michael crook now
this guy believed that it was good US
soldiers were getting killed because
they were getting paid too much
Hannity grew him into the ground as you
can imagine but what is this sensation
isn't doing it makes the Fox viewer here
a much easier to see the other side as
oh my god you are crazy you are
unpatriotic liberals get away from it
and the same thing happens on this side
I've seen that the comedy shows Jon
Stewart Colbert they pick the worst
examples to come out of Fox to make fun
of them and it becomes so easy so easy
to attach that label jeez you guys a
dumb
you guys are rednecks so this
sensationalism just just pushes this
polarization to a new level then this
the repetition the repetition of the
24-hour news format there's obviously
not 24 hours worth of content then so
what ends up happening is the same
content gets repeated again and again
and as advertisers will tell you what
happens when you repeat something again
and again what happens when you repeat
the same image again and again the same
sound again and again well some of that
stuff gets burned into your subconscious
and I can't help but wonder what
influence that's the current media
format now have on us that we're not
even aware of
and lastly poor journalism and and this
is unfortunately I think everywhere now
recently you had MSNBC try to link MIT
Romney to the Ku Klux Klan
they just lifted that out of a blog
unverified and reported it as news what
is that that just gives this side
ammunition ammunition to clearly point
the finger and say how biased are you
and the reverse is true as well
as Fox chops and changes Obama's quotes
to create something entirely new again
makes it so much so much easier for the
people here the point that finger and
say Fox how biased are you so this
combination of sensationalism of poor
journalism of repetition is this is
almost like a nasty cocktail and if you
drink too much of this stuff I say you
start becoming intolerant so now is the
moment of truth I will one day leave the
US and go back to Australia but before I
do that I do want to leave my mark here
I do want to share my cherished lessons
from Flo and Ray those lessons of
tolerance of hearing the other side by
creating a new voice a new voice that
fills this gap this current need a voice
that brings and improves the
polarization a voice that shows good
journalism still has a place in the
media business now I was actually
invited by Anne Grimes
she's the the director of the graduate
program in in journalism to attend a
media entrepreneurship course she's
running in the spring and to try and
breathe life into this dream but I can't
do it alone and this is my ask I'm
looking for three people three people
who share this passion and want to try
and create something new in this special
space
in this special place they can bring out
a tolerant tolerant voice that's not too
far from either side of this political
spectrum and for those of you here who
aren't students we will be needing
advisors so if you share this passion
please I would love to hear your
insights please drop me that business
card and with that I thank you
you